this here it is are we on oh we're on I
never know when we're on you know what
it's fine dude I'm so I'm so stoked that
I got you to come here I can't believe
you agreed to doing this oh yeah most
men agree to do things for Kate they
never thought they would yeah I wish
that was more true there's not as true
as you think but thank you no but like
for well okay first of all I'll
introduce you I'm so professional this
is my good friend Kay bond who is a
hilarious comedian actor you just
wrapped a show called top 30 on Fox yes
I was a newscaster I can't have to be
funny at the same time how do you make
the news funny cuz the news is so
[ __ ] depressing part of it is picking
the right topics like this is an actual
news story a third baseman was hit in
the balls with 106 miles per hour faster
hour oh [ __ ] and I said I need to cover
that on the news that's very newsworthy
and then I wrote it for my co-host to
read it and she's like a cute girl and
she had to read you know Juan Uribe was
hit in the testicles
with a hundred and six mile power ball
his testicles are inflamed and doctors
say his testicles were I just made her
keep cuz I wrote it she had to read
whatever's on the prompter dude did he
really get hit in the balls 100 mile an
hour fast no this is the best part a
hundred and six mile per hour ball off
of a bat yeah and the best part was he
wasn't wearing a cup most third baseman
wear a cup so he tweeted they don't make
them in my size oh my god in the news
that's ridiculous they have small cups
in the back you just have to ask they
keep them there it's funny that's funny
what happened to his nuts um actually
you might want to check in with them but
I think they're okay now is he cute
asking me like oh they're much smaller
now that's a hundred mile an hour
fastball that's got to be like permanent
damage like you could crush a nut for
good no they said they'd bounce back
you'd be surprised how we're seeing it
it's like a vagina yeah but it doesn't
feel know because the vagina would like
that first impact that's true the balls
like no never again have you ever been
hit really hard in the nuts
lucky to say no but is this like part of
your life
the podcast actually you want to hear
the best I can't believe I forgot about
this story this is the best like hit a
guy in the balls story you know I was
married yeah okay so I got married when
I was 19 and we took our honeymoon this
is so like cheesy from Ohio like
disgusting but we took our honeymoon to
the Poconos okay we went to the Poconos
like two nights and then we went to New
York City so we get married or driving
to the Poconos right first day as a
married couple we stopped at like a rest
stop on the way there some [ __ ] and my
ex he like was cleaning out the car and
he bent over to get a bunch of [ __ ] out
of the car and I went up behind him to
smack him on the ass as hard as I could
like I wheeled back and like hit him on
the ass as hard as I could and it I
didn't know that when a guy bends over
his balls basically go to the bat I
didn't know that I've seen Animal Planet
I'm 19 and like I was a virgin when I
married him so we'd only [ __ ] like one
time oh my god night before and and not
again for like a month after that I hit
him so hard
I mean like all my power and he just
dropped to his knees and then order rest
stop by the way and like I don't know
Kentucky or something that's when you
know the honeymoon is officially over oh
my god I started crying laughing no I
didn't know that's where your balls got
like ladies just say you know when guys
bend over their balls are actually in
their ass crack basically it's true I
can't believe we've never been hit maybe
he was talking that well most girls I
know don't spank my ass from behind why
not usually going the other way
yeah by the way I just have to say
before the podcast started so Kavon I
was shocked
he came on the show because we're good
friends and this was high school we
would be the couple that should have
been because we're never gonna be
together why not
we're still the couple that should be I
think
kayvon by the way you you are I mean I
feel a little bad saying this cuz I
don't want out you on the air for what
you really are but I mean like you are
probably the biggest player I know oh
really
don't you I mean real talk like she
knows like celebrities sitcom stars
comedians that travel the world and
she's gonna say that about a guy who
lives in a yeah but you pull first of
all I see the girls that you hook up
with they're all like supermodel hot
they're super hot you also are really
good at seeming like a like the kind of
guy that wants to settle down like you
seem like the guy like this is what
would happen if we dated yeah we would
go on a few dates and you would be like
really sweet and you text me compliments
and you would not be worried about like
[ __ ] me right away
and then I would think you had like real
feelings and then we'd hook up and then
I would find out you're dating like 75
other women that would it there's only
360 days a year that means you see them
all twice three times a year
answer the question before the podcast
started I said how many women are you
dating right now and what was your
answer my answer is I don't consider
them a number and you know a lot of
rappers like I got hoes in different
area codes if you call a girl a hoe in a
different area code you're putting
yourself in a bad position I consider
them princesses in different provinces
oh that's weird I thought that you
answered infinite that's so crazy that
they didn't hear the princess part of
the story yes the thing is um I'm single
currently yeah and I know I'll probably
be married and when you're married
you're not allowed to do anything
wait wonder when are you gonna be
married well probably one day and the
way I look at it is okay look at it this
way throw my young fans you grow up and
you're in you're under your mom's
supervision from the age of one until
about 18 to 20 and then you leave the
house and you're single
until what like in your case you're
single for one month right when you got
married immediately true then you're in
a
family so and then you like if you would
have stayed married you would have died
you know it like 60 years of marriage
right I would have died oh yeah yeah I'd
married yeah I would have died marry
okay so you have a second chance now
check this out
wait what we have a phone call can we
put them on hold so Kavon can tell the
end of this all right okay so your life
is only so long the first 20 years
you're like a kid and then you have this
amount of single years and then the
married years the marriages do you want
them to be from twenty to a hundred or
do you want them to be from like forty
five to a hundred years old I want them
to be never again okay I always say I
want to be married half my life and I'm
gonna mean I'm gonna live till I'm 100
so no you're not you're so reckless I've
been on your motorcycle you're gonna
live 250 tops let's be real the heart is
pumping I'm moving 200 I'm getting
married when I turn 50 on my birthday
it's been decided we have to take this
call no one ever calls the show so this
is very exciting
Wow who is it hello hey what's up who's
this hey Spurs house it's a good name
spruce like a tree yeah all right you
sound familiar have we it's Bruce
Springsteen just calling about dating so
well obviously it is appropriate but
like when is it appropriate to get
flowers
that's a great question when is it
appropriate to give flowers I mean some
people bring a flower on the first date
I think I don't like that I don't like
that it's not easy it's way too cheesy
in fact I don't this is just my opinion
I only really want flowers from a guy
that I've been out with at least three
or four times mmm it's got to be like
we're dating
yeah it weirds me out when guys bring me
gifts before we've really before
established that thing another thing is
like when a woman comes to the table and
goes flowers I feel like that doesn't
count as you're gonna pay flower money
but you're not getting
our credit wait what do you mean you
know when you're on a date at an Italian
restaurant and a Mexican lady's like
flowers and you're like no cuz if I buy
him here it's still gonna cost 20 but
she's gonna be like you didn't put any
effort in this crap wait no actually you
know what I actually like when the guy
buys the flower Mexican lady this is
this is okay because if you show up with
flowers it's like you premeditated it
like you thought through it and you
don't know the girl well enough yet to
know if she's into flowers and that's
even her thing but if you're out and the
Mexican lady comes by with the Roses
which by the way and you buy a rose now
it shows me all these things number one
like you're a fly by the seat of your
pants kind of guy you're impulsive which
I like to you know that lady probably
doesn't have an amazing job if she's
selling roses at a restaurant so now
you're like giving money to someone who
probably could use a little cash and
then also it's kind of like it's cute
like cuz probably I've had a cocktail by
then so it's gonna seem like even more
adorable I think it's a good move on a
date mm-hmm interesting yeah I'll let
the lady answer that because they know
more than me yeah and then wonder when
you're actually in the relationship I
think the best time to give the flowers
it's when it's for no reason yes yeah
yeah no reason is what I was gonna say
it's a surprise attack it's like why are
you giving me flowers because you're
beautiful and it's Wednesday that's it
dude anything you give for no reason
Trump's anything you give for a reason
it could be like you could give me a
diamond bracelet on my birthday it
wouldn't mean as much to me as a card on
any random day Spurs are we helping you
are just confusing Fresno Oh soon I will
soon I keep getting asked I've just been
booked on stuff but I'll get up there as
soon as I can for sure go see her she's
very funny
so are you thanks for calling sprues by
spruce yeah it's a good name you're not
gonna forget him when you meet him in
Fresno like okay you're the one I'm
definitely gonna remember a guy named
spruce how do you think you come up with
that name as a parent like you're just
staring out the window at a tree when
you have the baby and you're like you
know what you're looking around your
place and it seems a little empty you're
like we need to spruce up the place I'm
sorry that's funny so back to you and
only wanting to be buried for half your
life half my life that's a good amount
of time we've married if you say man
that guy was married half his life that
sounds good you're really funny and
you're hot and like full disclosure
you're one of the only comics that I
actually considered like hooking up with
you're the only comic I haven't seen the
[ __ ] up so if you could just stand up
right now and take it out that would be
no I I don't sleep with comics you know
that I dated a comic but I don't date
comics as a rule right but you you're
kind of charming
and you know what it is I got on the
back of his bike oh yeah
dude that is a bucket and that is a
you're very athletic so I wanted to play
tennis you gave me a run for my money
but I got you on the bike you got me on
the bike the bike is is that your go-to
move with chicks you get them because I
think that getting on the back of a
guy's bike is like a panty-dropper the
first thing is most girls I would not
recommend getting on the back of a
motorcycle you don't know what kind of
driver this idiot is I am I am very into
safety and so that's true but you made
me wear like the ugliest helmet about it
was like it was like what special kids
wear like it was not cute I needed
something to fit your head [ __ ] I came
out with like with like a blinking
sparkly like bicycle helmet that I
wanted to wear with like the corns and
rainbows on it kayvon was like vito nope
you got to put on the March and like the
mushroom head helmet yeah sure yeah but
I mean before the show started I took
out my phone to check out some Achaeans
credits and porn popped right up on
phone because I watch porn like but you
were so shocked that I had porn on me oh
yeah oh you're researching something for
a show you're like no I watch it as
researching does that who I'm gonna date
next is what I was doing I was like who
who's next on the loop which girl has
that unlike on her phone like as the
last thing she saw two in the afternoon
today so that means her phone has been
dedicated to that website no I just I
don't I don't use the Google I mean I
don't use the chrome feature on my phone
much I use apps more you know what I
mean out Google search a lot of things
so the last thing I happened to Google
search was interracial gangbang
dang is what specific I know well that's
what I've been into lately but when I
pulled up the porn he was so shocked and
I was like you don't watch porn I mean
he said I don't watch porn
I make form which i think is hilarious
do you really do yourself know I try not
to what do you mean you try not
accidentally you know leave my phone
recording on the tripod facing the bed
no I don't because I do want to work for
Disney eventually he guys want I don't
want video footage to exist some things
are meant for private and other things
for public but I did one time I was on
tour and I had a nice young lady or so I
thought over at the place and I was
walking to the bathroom like at 2:00 in
the morning and I heard and I turned
back and she has her phone out she took
photos of you yeah I go what are you
doing she's like what what I go you just
take a picture and she's like no but she
had that look on her face so I go give
me your phone and I don't know her that
well to be grabbing her phone she's like
you're being a freak what's wrong with
you imma give me your phone and I go
through and like delete delete and she's
like that was really rude you don't grab
someone's phone I'm like you don't know
that yeah she thought she's been cute or
she gonna send it to her friends or have
a memory but I freaked out and then she
acted like I had invaded her privacy you
know I
Millennials you're so stupid you think
it's selfies no but you have a point if
a guy did that to a woman it would be
like oh look out guys I mean i-i've had
guys take photos of me during and not
tell me really because sometimes you
know you're busy you're like otherwise
occupied and you don't notice them pull
a phone out and sometimes they send them
to me later oh I feel really violated
when that happens that's not a cool move
I know I Photoshop them and send them
back I'm like if you're gonna leak it
make sure you use this one I mean yeah
no I'm kidding I'm really careful about
that like if guys take photos of course
because I don't want that [ __ ] to be I
once dated a girl she's like looking
around the room and she's like she's
putting like the laptop down and then
she like flip over all the phones she
was like paranoid yeah she was like I'm
gonna make sure this is a no technology
zone I mean that's my I was talking to
to a comic who is a pretty big comic and
he said when he brings girls home
he makes them leave their cell phone in
the other room he won't even let them
bring cellphones into the bedroom
because he's so paranoid of them taking
photos who was it
I'm not telling that's smart you know
that all the celebrities are doing that
now they bring out a basket and everyone
has to put all the technology yeah I've
been to parties like that where you have
to leave your phone in a basket but that
freaks me out too it's like what does
someone just leaves and takes your phone
out of the basket I know they just check
like they need to have a number and your
name associated talk to me about you
were on disaster day you were one of the
hosts of disaster day one that was a
while ago on MTV right 2010 and 11 it
was a cool show where people would go in
and we would prank them like girls like
it was all hidden cameras maybe five or
seven hidden cameras in a room the girl
would think she's going on a date her
best friend would be in a studio with
headphones and in my earbud telling me
how to mess with her friend the most
effectively to piss her off cuz nobody
knows what girls hate more than the best
friend hmm it's the brilliant you know
it's so true but also what girls like I
feel like if I put my friends in charge
of my dating life it would go better
than me running it myself like other
people know what your fuck-ups are so
tell
me about the weirdest disaster date that
you ever had on the like tell me some of
the stuff you did okay so each each
episode I was a different character and
so that made it really fun like one time
I had to be and these are all characters
that are already something you're kind
of into yeah even when I auditioned I
auditioned as the gym guy so I'm like
what are you gonna get and she's like
you know turkey sandwich I'm like mmm
750 calories you don't think there's a
better choice for you on that they like
that so they go let's build around that
and so on one of the distance one of the
episodes I was the gym guy and I was
showing her like I was like this chair
is so bad for you let's replace it with
a stability ball and that'll keep your
posture better your chest will be out
you're gonna look so much better on my
date and like the girls would be kind of
offended but kind of intrigued like
who's this trainer wait a second wait
again you were saying this to girls on
not on the date on the date on the date
I was like you know what I like about
you you have great shoulders nice chest
I can tell you work your abs but your
posture is horrendous you know what
could fix that she's like what I'm like
this and I bring out a big like one of
those big fans and I go here let's move
this and if you could get a girl to do
it like I just need you to stand up
please of course I would do that if they
start at Stan I know I got them if they
won't then I would have to back off cuz
if you're pushing too hard then you're
ready for the door you want to keep them
on the balance of almost running for the
door the whole episode it's almost like
negging it's like no ultimate and
negging which you also are quite good at
and another thing I was good at was
getting big reactions out of the girls
because I would say something horrible
and then look the other way if you say
something horrible and look at a girl
she'll cover right but if you're like
you know what I like you've got like
weird little like buck teeth that's so
cute and then I'll go I go tie my shoe
and their girl we taught you these
things or do you just know these things
or do the producers well they would give
you a character like three days ahead of
time like tomorrow you're gonna be
technology nerd and I would spend 72
hours googling and looking things up and
walking around I would even have a girl
hang out and like oh my gosh I have like
my heart's beating at forty five
gigabytes right now oh whatever I would
just try to throw in any
technology term and then I would think
of like what would a nerd have Oh a
calculator watch so that he could
calculate the bill before it got there
to impress his date no oh so I just
think of these credit and then in my
earbud would be a producer going you're
doing good and calculate it and say oh I
forgot tax dang it dang it dang it eight
point nine or whatever like he would
give me little ideas I'm like oh yeah so
it was like did you ever go on one of
these disaster dates where you either
were kind of into the girl and you felt
weird kind of pranking her and the point
or you felt guilty at all well part of
being a comic is you want to be on TV so
bad yeah it could have been a super like
Heidi Klum and I would have just like
ruined the date just because I'm like
I'm on TV isn't that so funny how like
you don't when you're in work mode you
don't like people are always like aren't
you embarrassed to go to like the DMV in
a bikini and do this and I'm like I kind
of am until the minute I'm on camera and
they're cool yeah because you know it's
for a bigger purpose and we have another
call actually is it who is it is it
spruce again twigs now my name is Dan
guys how's it going hey Dan great how
are you doing well I'm having trouble
getting my girlfriend to orgasm oh this
is a new thing for him okay it's a new
thing for me
so I'm wondering Kate did you ever have
trouble with that depending on the guy
was a day was it a thing that with a
particular guy you struggled with more a
bit more and like when you were younger
was it more of a struggle back back then
compared to nowadays
great question well there's a lot of we
have to ask you a couple questions first
how long have you guys been together
Oh 3 months 3 months 3 months alright
and what methods have you tried
wait no before that wait how how is the
chemistry otherwise like is it do you
have good chemistry we do I think we do
you're really attracted to her yes I am
very attracted to her
III think she she doesn't think I'm too
shabby either so the chemistry I outside
of the bedroom is beautiful the
chemistry inside a bedroom could use
some help so um do you know if there's a
relationship so we're still discovering
things about each other do you know if
this is a common problem for her like
has she had this problem with other guys
have you talked about it I know I'm not
hitting it but asking because some girls
like really I have never been a person
who has a really hard time achieving
orgasm but that is because I masturbate
a lot
yeah you know I know exactly how to get
now if like there have been a few times
I've hooked up with yes there have been
a few guys that I've hooked up with a
few times that it's really hard for me
to get off with them which means we just
don't have the chemistry and so usually
after like two or three tries with that
guy I just quit seeing them to be honest
I mean if if she masturbates cuz I
always tell my girlfriends who have
trouble getting off I ask them how much
they masturbate and usually they don't
masturbate much yeah so they're not
going with the controls I have gone
through most of my old tricks with her a
problem so you know I've kind of got
like DEFCON one through five and I've
slowly brought things up all the way to
DEFCON five here you know like reaching
reaching deep deep deep into that bag of
tricks
okay now maybe it's the chemistry thing
well I mean you're back to cave ons
question what what have you tried can
you walk us through like what you do
mm-hmm mm-hmm
so I don't mind hanging out down there
you know doing lots of order oil for
sometimes I'll hang out there for a good
half an hour and well you know really
really give it my
all losses not too much pressure a
little bit of penetration and and you
know some ice cubes maybe consider it in
that sort of thing but wow I thought you
were serious I'm kind of into this game
yeah like you chew like some peppermint
or some like cinnamon gum and then go
down it's good Wow yeah didn't know that
was a thing
jalapeno yeah try that game up put some
olivine you on your time I have to date
a Mexican girl hey no you don't all
right anyway so listen um for one thing
I just I want to say it might not be you
some girls really struggle to achieve
orgasm but I like guys that like it's
lots of foreplay and not necessarily
just going down on you forever but like
touch all of her body all of her body
and like tell her complement her a lot
because some girls if she's I don't know
what she looks like but some girls that
they're a little insecure about their
body they have trouble getting
comfortable enough to orgasm so if you
make her feel like her body is like the
hottest to you then that might turn her
on enough I think I could come just from
compliments one thing you could do is
tell her hey tonight I want to watch you
and see what you do
and then you just are a spectator and
then you're just copying like cheating
off her test
oh my god that's genius somebody
somebody told me that that's the best
way to see what kind of [ __ ] a guy
likes is to watch him masturbate and
kind of see how he touches his own dick
and then you know exactly what he like
just cheating yeah hopping off the test
yeah what do you think of that do you
think she'd do that I think those are
both brilliant brilliant suggestion so
the first one maybe take my time explore
a little bit more cover the whole map
see all the regions really really better
working and then and then the next one I
really really like just maybe take my
feet up and ask her to uh yeah Oh
I'll take note and go there maybe yeah
she might say well I do it in the shower
oh let me see that that would turn me on
so much and then you just in there okay
how does this thing work here oh I
really like it too I mean like there's
this guy I dated for a while and we
would watch movies and like the entire
time we'd be watching the movie like on
his couch he'd be kind of like teasing
me like he'd play with me he'd touch me
but like I'd be like let's turn it off
and [ __ ] and he'd be like no watch the
movie
he was like turn me down and by the time
the movie was over I'd be so turned on
that we would have sex I come in like 2
minutes literally always blame her
because let me tell you something as a
comedian we do that - if our joke works
in every city and it's not working one
night in Ohio that's Ohio's problem that
is not our problem yes I like all of
these ideas these are all good ideas I I
hope that you call back and let us know
if you get off next time yeah we need to
we need to have a progress report by Dan
progress damn I like that mm-hmm
we came we have some good
counterbalancing ideas I think so why
haven't we dated it wasn't for lack of
trying
that's not true no I'm just kidding I
think it's good I think what do you
think about friends dating I think that
you know a lot of girls are like I would
hate to ruin our friendship I'm like
that's the easy way out how about if we
actually do that and maintain a
friendship after that's hard that shows
there's a lot of work and effort and it
shows your true friends but I also love
the fact that you said after because
that already means in your mind there's
no future for any relationship with
anyone you're like well after I'm done
back
like the girl is like if I [ __ ] my
friend it's like a real like I have a
guy friend
right now who is like one of my closest
friends he's SuperDuper hot I'm
attracted to him and I kind of even
might love him look I love it I
definitely don't have to talk about me
in third person I'm right here I've
never hooked up with him because I know
if we hooked up it would go from zero to
relationship like overnight okay so so
what about like like girls don't have
reverse have you noticed that yes girls
only have Drive you're like an old like
lawnmower you can only go forward and to
get us a turnaround you got a like sweat
and get out and crank it around it would
be nice if girls could back up a little
too well I have been trying to back up
like I've been in some relationships
lately where I want to take it a little
quicker than the guy and so I am trying
to back off but the problem is when
girls do back off we're only backing off
because in our head we're like if I just
back off a little then he'll see that
I'm the one and then he'll cut so really
its fade it's all manipulation reverse
how great would it be if we were just
real if we were all just real that would
be tough I don't want to ponder a world
like that why what if you were just
honest with a girl listen can I just
tell you how much I would respect it if
let's say you and I just met and we're
not both comics yeah okay let's say
we've met over on Instagram or Twitter
which is where I meet most guys I date
so let's say we met on Twitter yeah and
I'm like oh my god you're you're cute we
should hang out and you're like cool
yeah and we go out and I asked you like
so what's your deal are you trying to
like date someone seriously you just
look into hook up like what's your story
mm-hmm what would you say be a hundred
percent honest for me if I asked that
well because here's the thing because so
many girls would ask that in fact I'm
cool with whatever you say but really
they're not so as the guy your default
position is yeah you know I'm up I'm
open to like a serious relationship of
course with the right person I guess
we'll have to find out but it's a lie
but you might really just want to like
you know bank' for the night okay but
here's my thing if you were like you
what to be really honest with you I'm
just looking to hook up I'm looking for
casual I'm looking for dating yeah you
know who could say that like George
Clooney and other celebrities okay
totally disagree because listen if I if
I if you told me that from jump in my
head a lot of women get to a point where
they're like all right then immediately
they're like this guy's just a sex guy
uh-huh and they put you in that category
it's not an iPad guys in the just sex
category I have had one guy in that
category now for almost two years that's
all he gets a sex in fact he's not even
allowed to touch me
tell us your secret I'll tell you his
secret here's his secret when we have
started talking he was super flirty is
super hot and I was like let's go out to
dinner and he kept blowing me out for
dinner and finally I was like what is
your deal and he said I'm just trying to
hook up you said it and I was like well
I'm not really that girl sorry and then
one night one night you because drunk
and I was really horny and I messaged
him and was like you know what why don't
you come over and have a drink at my
place and we hooked up and immediately
set the tone that that's all it would
ever be and it literally is still that
Wow
well maybe that's a new thing a lot of
people don't have the guts to go that
route I know but here's this guy famous
it's humane humor make it sound like
like you just rescued a dog or something
no I'm saying it's the humane thing for
you to do there's another there's
another make the humane choice in the
arms of an angel
tell Kate you just wanna bang her
because there's another guy and this is
what you would do I just know it there's
another guy dated and after like he was
like hardcore trying to date me he took
me out on three dates before he even
like tried up
he called me all the time he'd text me
every day and then the minute I was kind
of like you know this could be like a
real thing he was like why why I'm just
trying that this is just casual and then
he backed way off immediately and what
I'm saying is if that guy had just been
real from jump it would have been great
cuz I could have had him in the just sex
category now I can't have him at all
because once girls have feelings you
can't erase them they have no reverse
can guys can't either if you catch
feelings for a girl and then she dumps
you and you still hit her up for sex you
still have feelings you probably do yeah
yeah but we're solving all the world's
problems today this is a good day I
think so I feel like what's your go-to
on it how do you ask girls out Kavon
good right I see you get hit on
constantly
well there's like a lot of channels to
meet women these days there's bumping
into someone at a Starbucks in line yeah
are you gonna say hey know if you're
there for 45 minutes waiting you might
as well chat or in an airport or
something there are flights delayed
yeah okay that's one you can go out for
drinks that's where people are kind of
like zoo and not zoo animals but like
Safari animals how they all go to the
watering hole and all their butts are
like facing out and then you just walk
up like what's up girl so that's we do
that by the way we totally like lean on
the bar and like stick our butts out on
purpose yeah if you watch the Discovery
Channel and you see the hippos and like
elephants going to the watering hole it
looks like the girls at the bar like
yeah and then you got to work your way
in there like a little hyena what's up
girl do you buy girls drinks um I try
not to cuz you don't drink yeah and
that's a great reason buy me a drink I'm
like I'm not even drinking why would I
buy you one yeah but there's something
really hot about when a guy doesn't
drink but he pays for your drink anyway
yeah
looks like a predator you get four of
these I'll have none that's probably
actually why we've never hooked up
because you don't drink so anytime like
came on let's grab a drink he's like I
don't really drink but you can come over
and watch my sketches yeah you do have
great schedule they're fun ya know
people should check out his sketches
they really are awesome on Facebook or
follow him on Twitter at cave on comedy
that's right probably giving you a shout
out thank you
what's the worst date you've ever had um
there was okay and I talked about in my
stand-up but the worst date ever was a
girl I met online and she told me oh you
know they send the selfies and the
pictures and very few clothing and the
duckface and when you cuz you're famous
it's Korean this Latino girl if you're
ever in Texas oh my gosh it's gonna be
so hot so I get there I happen to be in
Texas like a month later I'm like what's
up she's like come pick me up so I get
my little rental car pick her up she's
like this is your car I'm like it's a
rental car she's like still why did you
rent this one oh who cares then she's
like I want to go to like a really good
fish house and so we go to this place
and she's orders Lobster off the menu
and I was like oh holy [ __ ] the balls on
that chair yeah and then she wanted
white wine and she was explaining how
this wine goes the best with this but
she does want to try the other one each
glass I was looking at about $20 a glass
she's having three of those I'm going oh
okay but she all the pictures so I'm
like this is hot in person and she
wasn't okay that's good and then after
she's like well I just want you know I
had a really good time and let me know
when we can do this again I'm like what
like the bill just came she's like yeah
I had a fun time but I was like so the
dates over she's like I don't do
anything on the first date I'm like you
do a lot of ordering on the first date I
have $200 for the damage on the first
date so wait she didn't even kiss you
nothing no she doesn't do that on the
first date did that make you want her
more no not after I was like she texted
me so when can we go out again
I was just like I'm not you we're never
going out again
you spent $200 yeah and the thing was
she was like mmm should I do you want me
to help you know one of those fake and
she did yeah but she said yes but at
that point we were not that that point
we're still on the date but then after I
paid and everything you know getting the
car she's like thank you so much I just
you know and she you know who knows if
she's on her phone now I just fed her
Lobster and drinks and she's texting her
go-to guy to be honest she probably had
a great night and he's like dang she's
super turned-on that's because Lobster
is aphrodisiac so I help somebody out
there and that was the easy thing for me
to do that night I mean okay
a few things about this number one I do
think it's partly the guys
responsibility to I am NOT a girl that
goes on dinners on a first date yeah I
don't like to be trapped right yeah two
hours yeah [ __ ] that happy hour that is
my first date go to happy hour or coffee
like I'm super hungry what were you
thinking girls because here's a problem
I have a lot of girlfriends in LA who
are like they're always lecturing me
they're like Kate you need to make guys
take you on a nice dinner on the first
aches it sets the tone blah blah blah
whatever right yeah I've had so many
guys take me on nice dinners on a first
date it doesn't set a tone it doesn't
matter they're gonna treat you how are
they gonna treat you after they bang you
regardless I don't believe in all this
like if you make him wait X amount of
time he'll respect you more I make guys
wait until I want to [ __ ] them I want to
[ __ ] them I [ __ ] up
I don't like go date five date seven but
I mean here's the thing I don't hook up
with a lot of guys because I don't go
out with a lot of guys cuz I'm busy and
that's why I have to have a couple on
call for when mama gets thirsty it's
true it's true but like the thing is
that if a guy takes me out to a nice
restaurant I assume he can afford for me
to get whatever I want I would never
have the balls to order Lobster cuz I
try to go like yeah
but I was like let's go to this place it
she's like no I want to go to this place
I'm like what about this no I wanna so
she had it all picked out and that's she
had a plan she probably dates for meals
you know what I'm used to being the guy
like where I'm like hey let me take you
out yeah I can grab the girl take her to
my favorite place whether it's a taco
shop or a Cuban arrest or whatever I
have in mind and I know there's nothing
in Versailles Cuban restaurant menu
that's over $25 a plate well that's a
great place yeah it's fun and they're
playing music cool and we go to a comedy
club I don't drink but they give me free
drinks so I'll give you one of those
cool you take girls to your shows as a
date I have before yeah it's a great day
it's a great day if you're a male
comedian and you're funny you take a
girl on a date and you sit with her the
whole time but then you're like I'll be
right back
please welcome came on and you walk up
you're like good night now she's heard
like first of all she's seen other
monkeys clap for you like and all the
girls when Kavon goes onstage you're
like oh who's that it's literally like
you can hear like the pre orgasm like
throughout the room it's true I've seen
this [ __ ] at comedy clubs every show
after the show forty girls line up to
kiss his ass it's totally true
it's if it's a big show it could be fun
but the thing is it's social like it's
like primal other monkeys are clapping
for you if you bomb you have no chance
of getting that girl's number or hanging
out with that girl because to the
society has decided this guy is a pariah
avoid him at all you're right and
actually I will say this I don't let
guys I date come to my stand-up shows
because I don't want them to hear my
material if they see my act do they will
never go out with me but what I do is I
have guys meet me like at The Improv at
10 o'clock for a nightcap
when I'm not performing because I know
how good it makes me look because
everybody that comes in comes over and
says hi and gives me a hug and I and the
guy goes oh damn all these dudes are
trying to get with this chick she
whatever it makes the guy want you more
okay you got your little Tech
I'm not gonna lie and also it's my
comfort zone too and I know everyone
there yeah so it's real easy if I'm not
into the guy to kind of like oh yeah
yeah yeah one more show tonight yes do
my spot now you can leave hang on we got
one more caller ID it's crap it's crazy
called a hey who's this hello they hung
up they got tired of waiting my mom she
told me to get off this program
immediate probably the guy I'm [ __ ]
it's so typical of him to not answer no
but it is true like one thing I like
about if a girl sees your comedy it's
kind of like being on three dates
already because she's right hate it and
your stand-up you're talking about your
family you talk about how you feel you
talk about maybe an embarrassing story
after five minutes it's like you just
went on three dates that's why I don't
like it though cuz then I feel like it
the guy thinks he knows me and he kind
of does and then also I you know my act
I'm like very open about some crazy [ __ ]
that I do
I don't want guys to know not setting
yeah your act is hilarious it's also
based on truth yeah and if you here's
the thing though if you date a comic you
have to expect that they're gonna be
nuts we're all [ __ ] insane you Mouse
get pretty well though which is
impressive like you don't show a lot of
crazy but it's obviously there you
wouldn't have this job I mean it's a bag
yeah this job this job and but there are
some people who walk out on stage like
that guy is insane
you can tell from the beginning yeah and
that makes them funnier I agree
especially when they look crazy like if
they're like little pudgy people and
they get naked anyway I feel I feel good
about this I feel like this was really
we did well you we educate it kayvon
you're a great guest by the way because
you really do score well with girls and
you do have great game you really do you
don't over text you complement well your
hands let me smell good he has good game
so I feel like you guys that watch the
show if you have more dating
relationship questions you should tweet
a tweet on my cave on yes he's actually
you're probably a good person to answer
that trick yeah
can help but the one thing I have the
big cheat is stand-up comedy cuz if a
girl can Google you like let's say
you're just a regular dude and you work
at some import-export company okay you
could be a serial killer she has no idea
but if a girl can go on YouTube and see
you have videos and you're gonna be in
this city next week and you were in that
it's kind of a track record you probably
haven't like murdered and raped a bunch
of people that is probably true but
there are murdering comics and rapey
comics I know for me I'm one of the
victims
I am the 51st victim because people
think comics might be for weird
we're not oh that's so funny perfume oh
my god all right well I wish we have
more time to explain how you use sales
tactics to pick up women because that
was my favorite thing next episode when
I have Kavon back you were fantastic
where can people find you just google
kvo n I am on the internet and anyway
you message me Twitter Instagram
Facebook or YouTube you can get two free
tickets to my next show if you mentioned
Kate thanks for listening guys you know
I'm at Kate cue funny this has been date
fails on all things comedy see you next
time dude you're so great